ice time super excite bynight sachs
mobbing million and special guests of pop
ups at bars a bunch topix and commerce
company of at work it and see treat box
stefano stefano suigo time facebook
in short mask speaks aimont stress
day one in mass of bondo world of coni
michele  my possible and it is not known if
you are talking about the premier
[Music]
no recently
and it is stopped at premier stage ahead of 6 oct
and no more if not the praise has a function
and the stock option but not mater fog
the software  home that already starts between via
and juve long acronym to the function he
always knows where he loves 3d tron ​​flying more if
the tantrums of the river years vokey st after
hearing mekong metron plus
the ingv communication in conversation and
massimo bongio serve to apologize killzone
pure conversations and  sa even and panco
da ronco with shaun white homme waka
tablet is prodigious again with strings
the corrections of who you the shroud
traction a partner like bwin to me to
[Music]
talk to her doctor people marcelo
of the ong concrete specificity pvp paschi
[Music]
usual of s
you buy pause top with the both so
from brussels the funk werner and if there is that
nice eagles like diesel and jealousy
feel a downtime hear hear the mont
conficker bills to a blog  with with
decoration the buoys here sometimes from 2099
beautiful from the world of design if it exists
say bonjour and my end everything is
still set
mons nerazzurro toschi
line from the net told you two positions and opinions
that sucks sucks palette suite
sucks tone motions  that at the base of the
box and one design von pauer key
continuity 12 at home like a and paris doesn't
make one of the young 9 is a well with him
at the ball the elysium or boss nino senile or
who separate smartphones this of the
paolo landi scones who  has more and two
categories
two facts are taken a bit tom and keys
their house a bit as if they made
object lewd the act responses to no
ask ladies consumption champions with
sectional stick the distance if parcels
as well as cheese on the 17th it was known
eto'o yes no
and stop can't even visas that doesn't
consist of the states yes motion italy
after sheehan italian fact
italian bankitalia attack on japan of
accumulation japan you take
italian background second i give a pole and
valiani spain if you pass
so right and very right at the debut
our hubs asserting and mentioning at the
distance anglisti chile spanish
italy italy and perhaps italy and the few if
not the minimum attack
distance cure distance and hong kong  top world knows
if object opens jalan divides between
agliana glia design dvd o book despaigne
foam nexans chicken viruses
are few sites o trexta booked i
risked tokyo world sadepan a
china branch pandas 2 bis sa some yesteryear
82  made eyes of the poles after may say
if aim for saints of md varietal to
switch mail list of poles your
easter seeds in bakwa if I die dalmonte in
conos
tyson gay medium waves co2 militias you
are not 2000 and said no 200  0 old
man will kiss a demo to damon having
received this gift I have also taken into account
that it is no longer such a debt and is worth more
apcom when I was in lassini and not as
you see it being comfortable already rumble and post and
blocked not dirty if you win it yes  moves
as if in convoy katana instead of between
lucy shock the two giants papal tutors
need to move noir a complaint and off
houses ally two shovels too shall pass that
is, of shaboo of ron with here and at night he
does with I ask what of the pom poms at headquarters  then
the effects of hodgkin and the events that
happened as if he is in any case on guard
probable moggi
you will go pato
we come to a decided concept mini socket
disney.com g p net
the species is still in line or
monthly year simon and compare them we combine neither
her  nor from the name moved if everything is done to
six languages ​​and rainews assotir or breast
to france being both italian i would like to
know what points in common
you had for language learning he
suggested what you think is
essential  and the commandments of
the Italian mother tongue polyglot by
henderson and as I said before then
starting with stefano gladly
first of all how nice it is to speak Italian
with you even in the language that we
always use that we have always used
since we have known each other also a little strange to
use other languages ​​we do not have  never
spoken other languages
except perhaps in English sometimes
however coming to the
answer
I believe that the first commandment even
if a bit strange to speak of commander
golden egola xvi is common not only to two
but to the vast majority
of language lovers the  motivates if there is one
thing that probably the most important
we say the most important factor
in my opinion is motivation and
awareness knowing being aware
of why we study a certain language is
this I find this
awareness or this because this
voice that tells you the  because seeing
accompanied throughout the
learning process is not sol  or
something you start with and then canvas of minds and
because there will always be moments
during the study in which you have services
although in Italian you have an idea of ​​relaxation
you have athletic doubts
that's exactly sometimes the moments of
difficulty let's call them moments
of difficulties where you don't know which
way to go and this awareness,
in my opinion, in a corner of the brain
always present helps you to give yourself
the momentum it helps you to overcome these
moments the second big factor for me
personally the fun that is I
only do things  that I like
may seem strange but
very rarely do I find myself doing
some activity that has to do
with languages ​​that I don't like doing in my opinion it
's fun to do something
willingly because you want to do it and you don't
have to do it is what allows me  to
learn and to learn even more
effectively, i.e. in terms of let's say at the
same time
I learn the world much more effectively if
I do this  something that amuses me may
be if I speak or read about a topic that I
like very much and that I have to read in any case that I
would also listen to in Italian,
not necessarily in the language of
this, for me
another thing is fundamental another golden rule
according to  me is the fact that i don't know if you
've heard this before but one is more than
zero it's much more than zero nago 1 it's not
just a little more than zero it's much more than
zero what's your forte
this is the  workhorse yes in the
sense that especially for those who have a
family and also dad cedra and a few
policyholders as
soon as you have five minutes it
is not convenient to think ah no only five
minutes is not worth
it but yes it is worth
doing even just one  simple thing
listening to a sentence constructing a sentence
having a thought anything
any exposure to the
target language we say is much better than
doing nothing
so even if it's only five minutes let's
not put it off but do that something
let's do something because then something has
a much higher value than what
it may seem
and
[Music]
finally I would say something that perhaps you too
have said several times in many
readers trying to open the doors I don't know exactly
how it will open the doors of rome  of
one's life to the language we want to
learn this means surrounding
oneself with input tools in the mere
foreign language setting up let's say setting up
one's life in such a way that one almost has
to use the language without
realizing it or without really having to go
without making extra effort to
have to  use
I mean of course to
meet people or applications that
allow you to get in touch with
people all over the world you can
chat with people who are in china and
japan without his problem can you
can talk on skype you can  looking for a
flower you can look for a
language partner yes you can you can subscribe
to magazines on the subject as I said
before  they are very interesting
and that you can
still use them even in your area your
mother tongue can be done in
foreign languages ​​sure what I do
here in brussels which is a very
international city frequenting shops and bars
where the owners or those who frequent those
places
they speak the language that interests you and you
hang out with them and you speak that language
even every day if you want and
whenever you want you can go to the bar to drink
a coffee, speak for example in
Portuguese next door
so this is a bit of a secret, also to
keep the  languages ​​not just to
learn them this is key plus
earlier this year if i
say one more earlier this year there
was a morning when noon came
and i realized i already spoke
ho  used eight languages ​​at noon it
was something that doesn't happen every
day and a bit of an exception but I
said to
myself I haven't actively tried to use
these languages ​​yet
not even halfway  day is already
I had used eight languages ​​including
Georgian because I discovered that the
mother of two children who go to school
with Georgian as I have also used
Georgian the bus stop when
using Georgians a bus stop
means  that you have won the day can
end live in the present
before noon that you can go
home happy how great that you are external
like azzurri then as far as I am
concerned there are obviously some
things that overlap some she
yielded so I will tell you what I think
I
the most important the weil you said
but I repeat it because for me fundamental
is why the motivation comes from
because you need to know why you do something
very often people who
give up is because they don't know that one
of the things that almost happens  always in
any activity you start is that yes
the first week great enthusiasm
I do this I do this other for
languages ​​start the sport with go to
swim in any activity
and then there is a downward spike
in motivation which is completely
natural, various books also talk about it
and the moment when what makes the
difference is clarity of ideas why
do you want to start a
particular language before  starting a
language city I always
think about it very well there are always these sirens who
call me they often ask me but matt
hooper who has learned this this
language this other I always answer it's
not if I choose the language
the language that chooses me in  somehow it
leaves clues i went on
a trip somewhere i
liked the country i read a work of
literature
i met an interesting person
i saw a crack book and that
suddenly makes me want to
explore this country and who has more
put it at that point, however, it is important to
understand that watching a film getting to know
a person is not a reason it is
perhaps necessary for me but not sufficient for then
between  crossing in quotation marks overtaking
the obstacles that are
necessarily and inevitably on
our way therefore understanding why
knowing exactly why it is important
like you creates motivation over time
another thing that is important
to me I am not saying that it is general but in particular for me I realized  that
reflecting on myself what is
fundamental about it is that I
always visualize in a conscious way
at the beginning during the months the first
weeks how I will be in the future in the
next two years speaking and using
that language in the future and in every
single time I sit down  to study
any language whether it is Greek whether it
is Hungarian or Danish I already project
myself my mind automatically
projects itself forward and tells how
beautiful it is how beautiful it will be to speak
which language to use the language because
for me it is  lingua doesn't live in a
vacuum as they say in English from the salon
of the old women but it is a living entity
therefore unlike other p  oliglots or for
language lovers i have none
there is no criticism about it i
never see a language as something i
can learn a little if i started it
that is one its a mission it is to
integrate into something in one's life
to change it enrich it  so it's not
yes I know how to say hello and it's wonderful if even
a single word someone said to a
foreigner fills him with joy
but for me it's like a mission I know
you said the same thing to me
yesterday too so let's agree let's
agree on this third point from
second point so many say
knowing how to project forward and knowing
why motivating yourself is fundamental without
this you don't go anywhere like
having a ferrari without petrol you can
also have the best method on
earth but there is nothing to do
the second for  me is planning in the
sense that I'm structured enough
that he showed up yesterday too maybe
even then too maybe too much in
the excessive sense there's no need  to
be so structured other sorry but
there are that is one there are these
green parrots that create looks like a
one each every type 20 seconds there is this
last one go easy it's
beautiful
we hope and the parrots are beautiful
to see to hear it depends after five
hours with this twitter maybe a little
too much anyway thirds the second thing is
for me is planning things or is it
something that taught students to
distinguish planning
from execution that if you plan
saturday sunday to this i will do it for
this week then you have  just to
do i recently read steve
jobs in a in his biography now
i can't remember which one he didn't change in he
was famous for never changing into his
pants he was always hit
by them the same way and he said the
reason he always wore the
same  way is that it allowed him to
save the energy of having to think about
what he needs in the morning here is for me the
thing is very similar for  Because Saturday and
Sunday I already plan the whole
week in such a way as
to avoid having to choose what to
do, how to do it and when to do it during
the week which is fundamental for me
especially when it comes to managing
14 languages ​​and therefore more structured 6 and
the better it is
if you want to have a certain lifestyle and
let's say as a polyglot
let's say so my advice is also
for people who are not with lots
want to learn a language
at least structure their day to know
exactly what to do
is one thing  plus then they can relax
with the experience they can do as they like
so this is another point
in my opinion quite important
as far as I'm concerned it's third there are so
many but third invest time in
understanding how which is the best method
for the single person  to learn a
language and this means that there are
fundamental principles that apply
to everyone but the methods are very different
me  and you maybe we have reached a good
level of polyglotism they called that
it seems like a disease failure primates
but we have very different methods very different styles
and this means that you
do things that are good for you I
do things that are good for me it's
integrated  in this third point is the
fact that you must like what I do
every time I sit down I have a lot of fun
unfortunately I tell myself this
half hour has passed these 45 minutes now I have to
go back to doing the
housework but the reality  is that I would be there
all day he has to learn
because it amuses me so much so
never see the language as something
you have to do that is boring we unfortunately
inherited all this from school he
forget school i mean don't
leave it alone it's important but
as for the language that you have to
learn as you like while having fun as
hell I can assure you
please please
I meant my advice  it's an
advice that I give to my students when
they say to I have to study more vocabulary
I have to study the subjunctive more I have to
study pointing feet or do you want let's
start with you let's start talking about
I want to learn Italian better I want to
learn grammar that month and it's
all  a matter of corn is, however, already
gives you a different impetus starting by
saying I want to learn that thing
compared to I have to learn
that thing you already feel that there are two ways
of placing yourself in front of the object in
question is completely different in the
second thing that  it still means it's a
big difference between the two of us I don't
plan practically anything
I go a little you can and you could use
a dirty word but let's say I go a little
feeling indeed I go a little like this
feeling is pro or in any case a
structure because without without  the
structure this is true you get
nowhere
the structure for me represented very
trivially by the textbook with which it
began which m  i acts as a skeleton to
continue learning and and then
ono limited number of further
additional sources such as for example an
online vocabulary some let's say two or
three maximum youtube channel for video
podcasts i like how audio is but
here's for me to  example planning
too much would be counterproductive
probably because of how I'm made it does
n't mean as you rightly said there
is no universal way but everyone
finds his own a bit of looking for the beautiful the world
is beautiful because it is varied
who does the motivation we come sales
trash anbar slime constance they are
interesting no one was going to
answer normal stefano who has chance
under construction
[Music]
on the sentencing of spies my force the
invention of the gang by miss mister
typhoid fever what the design consists of
is dramatic
in aria by kamathi channels pstu
i update dic the dramatic matrix
nothing else has them not by chance it seems to me that they have
become man exact reasons
th log file  e knife humans at a talk at nas
aids in liberia the cloud reasons team
sky
now it's up to v but the limen saint martin
[Laughter]
notice shoot i do another one of the
trays small business new
interesting how to studio stock
shift highness all iceland
now  or never don't know if not suspended
formal traditions olive mlan sola
has bush culture traditions we mo
bast malware a global port said to feel
good a club high school fauna trends tan
dun cv sudan qua di fi and an frames
fergus space l  'iss ruspa rambla ban zona
niners for south face designer sparber
boot from rosarno and mailing la
[Music]
communication sold al voodoo sistine
sculptures by the tales a culture in a
garage flush with a ganz ex miss
luca prima goes a big thank you
from design  by lloyd by mark duggan it's
our ngan go nose wars so
italian company the change force shen
ying you with shock in a gazebo it's
hard for star dust by sky blues
al motifs aspes motifs  ani schwazer on a mix
sel is based on another son sport to
answer is important important
as long as on lusitano if i won't rule
over time now test the
crisis is therefore no let's create shoot me mini
derby where normally yes no i do it
why don't you show from  and i prepare islands
paris meaning why comrades tomorrow
how to hire
the pur times design gmail parure find
the step study a palmette of the language
nov
we express the we use the names year is
studied during 30 minutes to be able to tour them to
be able to study grammar with oneself
something then place  moved and a
half-oil norm boys in
marasco languages ​​einstein of food to meet
opportunity shoot bar to practice a
normal life and normally at 44 times it's
better to always say yes stories kurten
taiwo burns them in japanese
normally literature match has been
grammar as long as georgian grammar is
excellent insomnia problem solver as
standard grammar or two
toki conversations with sora helpful  zzare normally
I think no no no no cusumano
in short it's an agreement a sync event
domagnano magnago are the locations in your
posts
ghost while I'm preparing because I moved it ago
smith azzano I write number of hard edge
lesmo important for mine writes
pure as nus test  minus
cateria to write cabestan chain
idea on what the two then it seems to me it is very
important layer to face to see us 30
minutes on a book agorà august stoller
unlock chance senking faster past with
the two interesting then we study better now 30 minutes
1 language  at the moment stores study
hungarian gregu and denmark and snap sivo to
win sweat stress languages ​​store on
science the two then labor labor
creative need to write articles
prepare videos for youtube romanian with
a youtube car i spent and
after the fake or to talk rough  and for
me it's important to sleep a bit late an hour at the
den as long as yes no one is impulsive
because how outdoor pur example a north
sea the horsemen sleep mo  ment
important branches the two then from wow wow cso
coach 334 house falls spam
travail the two then on arm and important
break of 0 8 euro 30 minutes I always keep this
nemanja a plate 30 minutes minutes
different viruses example the magna o is a book
on  little more complicated until fast is
the one in naples salerno it was
complicated then i'm moved another thing
a design bond will do but it's a very
important step of the soils for how a phase the
things how to organize things yes
the two then it will be one story only  have a
mood book on an interesting closure of
numbers of fascism in time and in
Italian it's really stoner in Italian the
world of sofia or mundus will blow big
bags has written a book of the moment of the
rooms by history of philosophy
as it swing
ok a little alley turns swing  ad act now
studies study 30 minutes actively a
mood languages ​​mais depois as already
installed there was a cohesive that makes the
difference
here is a makes a mood swings as long as i
use buzz languages ​​spanish  the but the bait
for three months but sincere or falmouth cardia
because abnormal integration a peach
eastwood artists and stylized four
hours were then it is normal in countries
luxembourg the portuguese portuguese
portuguese luxemburg and francesco the
english man singh the paraplegics normal
all a normal form  the mini video
expenses found as long as in italy agent
paolo italian is on linux sergeant does
the american american command
the purists scene a normal tourist swing
to a part of humanity that does the
squad 5 normally in this
arabian weekend unit premium
the information  and co
[Music]
in flash just the way dei goals Ovest
and experience aspect
hand made in house and collect morin
speaking odling weekend
stefano io mi senti chi parla parla
stalking
ok features and flexdoor i fori nei main
means be nice
coach out  purismo options and then it by
stephen j
eden keep the king and half yoga keep
the king played in spanish holds sky
help me i quoted com  and I always
d'este always
[Laughter]
paradis and when this comes to have a
little what the adels I distinguish
sober robots spent something that gives me
the strength of thing that gives me a chopper the
real and live holidays and soul offers but  s
if you are of me
blatter and the epiphany you wait and
eliminated or not and what algo que
nous nous notes nor at lincoln i will hear
astra has little time it would weaken
turn into a canteen there is
impregnable and wide with what whole dear
and between were  century inter implement will try
interactive perfect no it is a
very special thing a very special moment
and in the province it is something else
the simple that must spresal whether to hold
an an exchange of ideas and opinions i
go out with ultras person with the school it is
probably luca luca yesterday as
hablar hungary hold if interchange yes no
yes no yes no plus example tambien and
reggio must help los otros in the
skin audience helping are not only
not only as as tutor as
when help  to the person to pick them
up thomas until tambien when in the calle
situation knows if you have people who have a
problem eno
solution harlow because of the shopping who
is neither brussels and in the market and one without
waiting yes no something a little rava
then when in a  universe recently
other ami ami me gusta to annoy stand
up comedy you don't know how inserted in
castilian but it is the standard and
how it is a thing to pull committed by
comedian sites by those who change them a thing
musical movie spice and intends
riri armea carca salas e  are the suv laser
doble some of the cyst exists rome
but ambient knows why you waited for the
cohen one of our languages ​​in the tank
ser linguistic fantastic as ami
bonato the same shock sky asti thomas
to the three last basically that for
me they represent a plus it was absolute
when one has an idiom tear the
first hero as bulkheads excommunication century
is and maximus all'arco los temas
all'arno alone will simply do them
Communicate and you notice environment talk
with the sna tive this tradition you are
history of film starlets nature of
subs in east and su culture ye are years
an incredible intellectual tamagno
do not deprive the communicate know emas
sin tener that go through
english and history and are  lowered
according to para i entrust a plus and
absolute as the trainings 90 est and
commented test that when i was in
spain in barcelona and how do you do franzi
to save constant support but we
hassan the idiom giving hand then an
incredible breath why change
another country  had on a little and
stressful sun and stress because it keeps
cards of the bitters you have a different system of how to
calculate italy which by
using the idiom the fate facilitates
life in a way that cracks in a
stressful situation and a plus time
of the series the same mother of horse
as well as carlo serìo never mood phase the
polet sinter implement with the school scheme
of the in the back span a
telephone afloat  l kilar incredible its above
my being on a brotherly because it held
in check the difference of the
misma experience that leans iter fero how
ardizio tu es
al arconati boss the surprise the reaction
of the sna tive save the ass for example
the how much the shock on  a heinz for
curd in this is a person who is
to say a group per person
I remember he gave a year a new
media metope with a group of Poles
who don't even know the vatican in
science and gò de repente jak and when
was it  in a group not need harsh
retards not despro that he knows he knows
plus he knew the shot say one thing of
polish assays i
sudden piazza salvatempo lacko of the os that if that not
as a painting Polish is spoken as long as
the reaction is a reward ensi
incredible following  a capable story or
iaf and the smash come out of the pandemic
what i can and which is the art for me system it
seems if sex on march 7 was a
test that the government wants from filio de
ferrari
we have two people and in the supermarket
that was expanding the and was
trying to remove a surgical butt and they
are presenting aargau since i was
happy with this supposed
communication in english but it didn't make
sure i además the same for me as the
people who know in the supermarket  non center
a vadena da why not the english
the owners of a month because i
alleged to the bosses and will be able to help if i
were her después hare punted
chirio massa online
this is the list maternal and when the c
rooms rive ungaro in pesarla lungaro
if that l  'he also has a mouth forbid as
which I will assume however because because one thing
is salar ungaro in budapest this
if hungary yes the sentence is good
chiavaro ungaro and climbed however it is
if hungary however the site area seemed with a
pole that at the  hungarian asi de suddene
rise the reaction stay demas lo que
está vampires endo was
dirty bus tickets and rome site where tonight
doyle domingo for the night could not
meet ticket  it was like I
feed spaces no western smas a bit like the
hall not being able to buy tickets with
women are the pores giosa that pushed
star bags of the paper mill
training sky fest a point that classroom
ungaro that the era of the ticket rocks for
free own  yesterday a di nero
regress home with a motivation how
will take ungaro because elected of the
poder the communicate being able to help the dna
a reward a happy to and the
masses to unite or but as lungaro which
is not only me but him anyway regress  he's at
home thinking super super animated no
how is heard aura he heard
he was supposed to be dirty he was
taking the riverside i'm going to give a
break sodic and why this is accusing
the skins you're always laughing if the
possibility that they shouldn't have sat
down  la vita non sta e sas
este possibility because it means communicating to you and i have
serious acclaim incredible
season compensation world takeri to
count its bourgeois history on u  na
spent in stand by
woe to go to a bit of his hard
squeeze out of the union he chased little he
added at home rhythm game muffler and
behind balls a couple a vestment
scanned and boobs that my
friend truly luca wrote the actor salomon and
king midas online i'm mass
it says mine non todaro the o from
why and there that leads to ios systems a
hobby mi station with ken jennings sirti towers
that you can see life lines change
kirillos savoia apparently bioster spa
for the web and  evans bored
i dreamed of seita and of count with the internet
i was there too the common clan in the
user alda on the sim accounts acting notary
dotarvi own xvi marbles i ask if 8
17 s sestio sanin totality yesterday you that
you is now suite hope  and the road by
maicon closes russian what a sorry red
cosca it was the axis neither yesterday nor
yakin josè imitating and i would say rai
sailing what god carioca card suit no
riddles feared it's just the
internet leaderboard housch to itself each
target a  session  nicole kidman sati
fusco insane hong soon o ma aiko absent
lists know i stupid i carra casta teli
o limit the titles it is not o
l'avola sinaia opina sita to understand once
the score
the unions ask
for the six fantastic is stopped but garage
band  movie islas canarias protection
scheme successful slow fish is well managed
robbie diack you find asks but i quote you
place super doc on tour ego music band
light a case the pillory yahoo google and away
with me todd gebhart co bowles who
knows picture asu songs and podcasts you
asked  hours pressures and of the stands pad
way the exits so indeed swingers who
solicits menton on who mini arctic is
enticed the me so so gretzky auction
minting man conversation csquare the
subjects and or globe film china youtube ne
youtube to age from age from
tax payer  rush wass nor yes yes
author tenie tourer film spread
bartz march weissman jah message was
she was a chef who is the mastermind the spray
on the nation's grapes demo on playsta  tion
and bananas taras tomovic
al 20 cross bones telephone and its new
york of chest or if he gave
it somebody upsets me youtube a chaos tag
was hit the seco accomplished saddens
samo i cross and what is behind is lou
duva osvart and  hoc born and bar where the
concentration u vague keep lethal
from the screwjob eta beta who put me the
internet key and tim goodman informed tac
al hayat the taxi mister micron daniel a
papier agra bard wagner olen data gosaf
team thanks spa pierre and the yes  the
cheaters with sketch arts cubana papi is
known wass ott chris the new and much le
tags dahlan isao rus new york arthur and
historical themes the generals and a half was
hoped focus in love with g grom black
her and himself maps castagnos phone and
gives me the dimension  this spa pierre
hugues lepic and environmental mood beach
games jesus minutes regulate ucei
after years asks iac hickson hobici
sorgenia top chef with super defense ibis
little 6 bis mega ok chrysler iphone
[Music]
click on stage
now I've given you a new one but as soon as
you open it, the uncle immediately speaks to you,
how are you calm,
don't worry, and they do a huge thing so every year
you stop at a calla I knew it, I knew
it's nice to hear you speak in Polish
luca you like it and  you could see that there was a
smile on his mouth and also because it was very
strange